d'ordinaire les manuscrits et les livres
de françois 1er sang conservé
chouchouter et compulsé ici à la
bibliothèque nationale de france
mais cette année 135 d'entre eux ont
décidé de passer l'été au château de
blois ils ont été emballés avec
précaution dans dix caisses sécurisées
et plusieurs balises scellés puis
convoyer sous protection
chaque pièce est emballé dans du papier
de soie puis dans les papiers bull le
tout autant scotch et numérotée pointer
les paquets sont mis dans des caisses
qui elles mêmes sont capitonné et le
tout est calé avec de la mousse
simplement tout est pointée avec délice
qu'on était un colisage à savoir que
nous avons une liste du contenu de
chaque caisse et enfin le tout est
scellé avec des scellés unis tient
ce sont des invités royaux précieux et
rare l'équipe de conservation du château
leur a donc préparé avec soin leur
chambre d'eau un travail méticuleux et
sur mesure car lorsque l'on est
manuscrits royal on se pose dans un
berceau quand il s'agit d'un ouvrage
d'un manuscrit il y à une reliure
donc il ne veut pas être ouverts
n'importe comment sinon on casse on
abîme la reliure donc avant au préalable
il y à des équipes qui vont prendre des
empreintes de ses ouvrages de
l'ouverture exact de l'angle dans lequel
il peut être ouvert une fois qu'on a
fait l'empreinte qu'on a il va falloir
donner à un fabricant en l'occurrence un
fabricant de supports en actu glace
parce que c'est un matériau inerte qui
ne va pas altérer donc la reliure
il va fabriquer d'après elle emprunte le
rappel à berceau en fait sur lequel on
va poser le leur les moyens techniques
de réception particulièrement élaborés
sont à la hauteur de la rareté des
oeuvres présentées certaines d'entre
elles n'étaient jamais sortis de la
bibliothèque nationale
dans cette exposition nous verrons à la
fois des pièces qui n'ont plus que
rarement été vu sinon dans les livres et
certaines pièces qui sont vus pour la
première fois puisqu'elles ont été
identifiés dans les collections qui sont
extrêmement vaste de la dnf donc des
choses qui étaient bien chez nous
numérotée classé mais on ne savait pas
qu'elle appartenait à françois 1er donc
c'est l'occasion de les découvrir pour
le public la bibliothèque personnelle de
françois 1er comporter environ un
millier d ouvrage vous avez donc mille
et une raisons de visiter cette
exposition